what i want to know is like what the
people want what the people has to say
[Music]
hi i'm zar larson
today i'm doing the wired auto complete
interview
what zara larson let's see what people
want to know
what zara larsen vocal range i don't
know if that's a
correct sentence my range i don't know
did you hear that my voice started doing
that it's like singing two tones at the
same time i find that kind of cool
i can't do it on command but rewind that
if you want to see it again
not that low very very high not ariana
grande high or mariah carey high
but pretty high what is our larson
symphony about i think songs in general
are about whatever you want them to be
about
symphony to me is when you meet someone
they just makes you feel
so complete it's not only an instrument
it's like a whole symphony
this song is just so perfectly on key
and you love the sound of it and you
just want to hear it every day and you
want to be a part of their life in their
little symphony
moving on what songs has zara larson
written
i started writing a few years ago and
the first song that i did
was never forget you with emini k
and another writer in the room was
astrology it came out so beautifully
so that's the first time i written and
then after that i've been writing a lot
i would say
in my catalog 50 of the songs i write
and 50
i take from other writers that are
really really talented
mostly people that i work a lot with so
they know what i like and
what i want to sing about what is our
larsen zodiac sign
zodiac sign my zodiac sign
is sagittarius
but here is a very
controversial thought i don't believe in
it
sometimes i believe in it if it's
positive i believe in it if it's
negative i don't believe in it
is zar larson one
of the f i'm the founder of ikea i'm the
founder of meatballs
i did indeed put abba together i wish
i'm not i really really wish i was
but i'm a big fan of ikea especially my
mom
sometimes like when we're bored me and
my mom just go to ikea
is tsar larson related to
henrik larsen no she's a very common
last name
it's like smith you know it means the
son of lars
if you couldn't tell johansen very
swedish
son of johann you would say in swedish
jackson
son of jack not that swedish is zara
larson
a soprano i would say i am yes is
zara larson all the time about
a girl this song all the time
from the breaking of the day to the
middle of the night all the time if you
want it to be
is zara larson on eurovision
no maybe you'll catch me there in 20
years when i
am really bored and i love love
love to watch it though i think one of
the best movies this
year was will ferrell's fire saga
the bullets i take for that movie
i think it's perfection honestly i cried
so much i laughed so much he really
embodied the spirit of eurovision i
thought it was just incredible
is our larsen on x factor
no i'm not and i have never been i was
on sweden's got talent when i was
younger
i was about 10 years old is zara larson
swedish yes
is zara larson related to
brie marson you see that
that's one s i have two
so that's a no is zara larson vegan
i'm not i think it's incredible if you
are also because
i'm an extremely picky eater i used to
always think that
i just had ice cold hands and feet no
you didn't eat enough that's why you
were cold all the time
and now i'm back have my appetite back i
feel more healthy so maybe now when i
have like a good relationship to food
i could try it out my sister is vegan so
when i'm home and she cooks i eat vegan
i think if you have a vegan choice and a
non-vegan choice
maybe i'll pick the vegan choice where
is
zara larson originally from sweden
stockholm
born and bred where did zara larson
go to school i went to school
in stockholm just a normal like
elementary school
and then when i hit 4th grade i
auditioned for the royal swedish ballet
school
and i went there until i was 14
and then i said i just can't be bothered
to dance ballet 40 hours a week when i
don't even want to be a dancer
where does zara larson
live now i feel like i don't live
anywhere i live out of my suitcase but
this year definitely specifically i
have just been in stockholm i think i'm
gonna try
l.a because you just have to try it out
you know i might go there and i might
say
this is not for me well at least i tried
it and i think everybody should try
the things they want to do where was
zara larson born stockholm sweden how
did
zara larson meet her
boyfriend i have a boyfriend and we've
known each other for years
just like friends in common how old
is zara larson i am 22
going on 23. how tall
is our larsen 160
centimeters and five foot four
does zara larson does zara larson
have siblings i have a beautiful
wonderful little sister her name is
hannah and she's just
the most amazing person in the world
she's everything i'm not
and that's only positive things does
zara larson
have braces i used to have braces i feel
like me and braces had a love story that
just we just didn't want it to end
and then it wasn't good enough like it
just was not good enough
so i had to like ah whatever no one
wants to hear this
yes i had braces and then i had
invisalign and now
it's like this does zara larson write
her own songs i do some of them i wish
that i wrote all of the songs i love to
be in the studio
i think it's amazing but i see myself
first as a performer
that's where i want to be i write my
songs or i sing the song so i can
perform them on stage
does our larsen have a an american
accent
well you design that you decide that i
think it's very american
i you know once upon a time i could do a
british accent and now
it's just gone i watch too many american
movies
what was sarah larson's first song
the first song that i ever released is
still one of my favorites it's so
beautiful
it was released in scandinavia and then
later on in europe and it's called
uncover
and it's a stunning ballad i just turned
and i really had to fight for that song
to come out because nobody else liked
that
i think it's honestly my biggest song at
least like in sweden
definitely over 10 times platinum
sometimes artists are like oh
that one song like oh i'm ashamed of it
never
i love that song it's so beautiful
what is our larsen ruin my life about
it's about when you meet someone that is
not really good for you
and you're like i know you're not good
for me but i really like you
and i just want to be with you even
though you might not
be the best option for me i'd rather be
sad with you than happy without you
weird right but if you're in a situation
like that i promise you there is someone
out there who will love you and
appreciate
you don't settle for the minimum
don't let the bar lay on the floor i
like that song because
it's very relatable to me and i think
it's relatable for most people
but just know you deserve better what is
our larsen
doing now i'm recording a music video
in a few days so i've been rehearsing
for that and um
i think i'm gonna direct it i'll just
have to speak to the director
and telling him i'm gonna be part of
this
because i have a vision what movies did
zara larson play in no movie yet
would love to be in one though there's
definitely musicals that i like
but i would want it to be about
something completely different
like not about music i don't want to
look pretty in it i want to be like
grudgy and i want to cry in it and i
want raw emotions
and i wanted to have a gray blue green
filter over it
kind of like if i would play an ozark
something you wouldn't like expect me to
see and you're like oh she can't do that
and then you see me on screen and you're
like she's
great
the confidence what languages does zara
larson speak
only two english and swedish they go to
spanish classes in school
um no hablo espanol
un poquito i can say
uh te quiero una lado por favor
thank you so much for googling me and
making this great content with me
maybe you want to know some other things
for the next video if i do one so just
google away google hella and then maybe
it will pop up in the search bar
and i will answer that for you thank you
for watching i had a great time